Troi and I met our sophomore year in
high school but it wasn't until at the
beginning of our senior year that I was
like hey I think he should ask me out
I'm done being friends yeah
On January 1st 2001 Troy got down on his
knee and said I was his best friend and
that he wanted to spend his life with me
how could I say no to that in 2016
I was diagnosed with breast cancer talk
about not knowing what to do
Troy has been by my side through every
step of the way
he has cried with me took care of our
two boys he has held me up
then in April of 2017 it was declared
cancer-free our hearts were just so full
and everybody was so happy we decided to
go to route 91 country festival in Vegas
[Music]
at first I heard what I thought were
fireworks
Troy knew at that time not somebody was
shooting at us
Troy rest over to get me out and we were
holding hands when he got shot in the
leg
Troy not only saved my life that night
he was credited for saving another 20
people he was awarded his second medal
of valor for what he did that night Troy
is an amazing man and I love him more
than any words could ever say in my time
and spent with you this is one of my
favorite stories but Troy was almost the
man that got away do you want to tell
everyone how okay so just between us I
will admit it was my fault so we were
highschool sweethearts and our freshman
year in college I was so excited I'm an
only child from a pretty strict family
and I was like oh my gosh we're gonna
get out we're gonna have some fun we're
gonna go party we're gonna let our hair
down and Troy was like you know I'm I
want to be a police officer I've got you
you're like my life I'm good and I was
like oh I'm like I don't think I could
handle being married to a cop which was
great because all the gang she wanted
didn't happen it was so silly
18 year old I didn't know what I wanted
so it was a blessing in disguise because
I got to go do what I wanted and needed
to do and Troy got to follow his path
and becoming a police officer and
everything and he's truly my best friend
Gold so has Troy always been sentimental
is he more the cinema one than you he
well yes sentimental that he's really
the one that does it so even in high
school he would write me poems do y'all
ever did y'all get poems or did you
write any poems sofyan I write some my
wife writes me notes all the time and
leaves them excited to travel so much
too but she writes notes and little
pictures of her and the baby and it's
really spent finding like in boot I mean
she really has gotten good at high
my husband will do that he's really good
of that it's sweet yeah my husband write
songs for me so you wanted to go big and
tell Joey how much you love him why I
have not been that fabulous I guess it
expressing to him how much he has meant
to me through the last three years that
have just been you know rollercoasters
up and down and you know he's just my
knight in shining armor and I just
partner in crime yeah and I felt like
reaching out to you guys to help me just
go above and beyond and do something to
you know make him laugh and have fun and
like really feel yeah how much he means
not only to me but to everyone that he
is come in touch with he's always been
[Applause]
so I got together with my band and my
friend Scott from pentatonix and we all
had a musical brainstorm session hello
Kelly Clarkson and Scott from pentatonix
just walked in this room I can't express
how excited I am writing a song for Troy
with Kelly's band we know he's like such
a here it is a good dude but we wanted
to just get some info from you from like
you know like how we could kind of pull
things like from real life so he'd laugh
at and take her funny to have the
opportunity to share little parts of
troy and i's life together it's just
gonna be so much fun so does your
husband have any nicknames that we could
possibly use my favorite nickname for
him is cabana boy Troy it's also my new
favorite names I've written several
songs with Kelly and most the time it's
you know with radio in mind or fans in
mind so this is the first time I've
written the song with just one person in
mind
watching them build this song about Troy
eyes life is more than incredible so
when was your first kiss speaking of
that when did you have more than your
first kiss
let me just say that um the movie The
Little Mermaid definitely stirs up some
really clearly I'm not holding anything
back
were you watching when you yeah I'm
having so much fun with everyone in this
room oh my god it actually cool bit
slowed down almost like or just meet you
I can't wait to ambush Troy because he
is gonna connect to every part of the
song he's not gonna know what happened
okay cabana boy Troy first of all thank
you for this that is awesome it's a
great hook so how did he get the
nickname cabana boy Troy so when we were
younger I finally convinced him to start
partying with me thank goodness right
and he is a party and a half so anytime
that we would have people over to her
house and hosting he would make sure
everybody was having a great time how to
drink had food so it just like came
about one time he was bringing a drink
and we're like oh thanks cabana boy
and we're like cabana boy it's been
within I love it
[Applause]
there is just one thing left to do
ambush Troy so a shaded invited Troy to
lunch and the place they go all the time
and he had no reason to suspect anything
was going on other than a nice meal so
just look well there's that
we were sitting there and of course
you've got Yoda in a glass so Yoda
snoring we're about to ambush a lovesong
Troy we're gonna ambush Lux on the crap
out of them it's gonna be awesome
I'll go are you Troy all right buddy
this one's for you
here we go we're coming in hot Troy go
camera one
April is you nervous are the trials I
think April and June are the traffix
[Music]
Oh
hi
are you try my gosh hey you it wasn't me
so much and then she was like oh it
makes a little bit cuz like maybe I
should enjoy like our lives and until we
do that then it was like magical and
we're all here now together and Janet
says you're pink so like can we all
party with everything
[Applause]
I know it surprised your face was
awesome I feel like you almost were like
no I'm not Troy I don't know what's
happening but did that surprise give you
all the fields oh yeah that was nice I
don't know thank you so much for doing
this I just want to tell you thank you
so much it is an honor it's an honor to
be here with you with the Wilson
Phillips with Ian you guys are amazing
that were you sitting on this couch time
Hey you're the hero you and saves lives
there's a shock for us
Tony Tony you stay here on two I mean
there's a lot of heroes out there and I
think we all just are here to be the
best we can right yeah well we're
supposed to be doing that I don't know
if everyone's following suit it was an
amazing surprise I I was sitting there
and Shannon gets me to come to lunch at
12:30 which is ridiculous because I have
lunch at 11:00 so I'm I'm starving and I
look right and you come out and I'm like
oh my god and then you hit this this
line from The Little Mermaid cuz the
girl and I'm like oh my god first of all
we're going to talk about this backstage
like I'm talking Little Mermaid
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Shannon oh right so I've always been a
person who is there for people and
helping people and I love my role in
life but when the person that you're
supposed to feel like this that's
alright but when the person I cherish
the most in the world puts out that much
effort and helps me through all this
stuff it I don't know what to do it's
amazing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we have one more surprise for the both
of you don't worry this one won't scare
you okay we're sending Shannon and Troy
to Hilton Playa del Carmen set in the
Riviera Maya region the all-new
adults-only resort is a perfect and
nightly entertainment set along sweeping
ocean views y'all it's time for a break
but I hope you'll have so much fun I'm
coming up in this Erin HIV okay I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this